196,4 millions d'euros c'est le montant
du contrat décroché par expertise france
avec l'union européenne
expertise france est un établissement
public est liée à l'afd l'agencé
française de développement dans le cadre
de ce contrat l'établissement a livré du
matériel militaire aux pays du g5 sahel
le mali le niger le burkina faso le
tchad et la mauritanie mais selon une
enquête de dix close et de mediapart
certains soldats appartenant à ces
armées ont été accusés de violations de
droits humains par plusieurs ong et par
les nations unies en juillet 2020 les
ong human rights watch a par exemple
documenté l'exécution extrajudiciaire de
plusieurs centaines de personnes par les
soldats de la force conjointe un mois
plus tard la mission des nations unies
au mali a publié un rapport indiquant
que les forces du burkina faso se sont
rendus coupables de -50 exécutions
sommaires quant aux forces de sécurité
de défense du mali les auteurs du
rapport les accuse d'avoir exécuté
94 personnes de façon arbitraire entre
avril et mai 2020 selon les deux médias
parmi le matériel fourni on retrouve des
blindés mais aussi des drones des gilets
pare-balles des systèmes de vision
nocturne ou encore des groupes
électrogènes disclose et mediapart ont
contacté expertise france pour l'agent
sa responsabilité je cite prend fin
lorsque la propriété des matériels et
transférés aux bénéficiaires elle
précise aussi que son soutien aux armes
et du g5 sahel est un soutien non
létales de son côté l'afd a fait savoir
aux deux médias qu'elle exerçait une
vigilance sur la façon dont ce matériel
est utilisé sans pour autant donner de
précisions sur les moyens à sa
disposition pour le vérifier la france
est extrêmement vigilante aux conditions
d'emploi et d'utilisation des matériels
et financements apportés aux pays du g5
sahel
toujours est il que rien n'empêche à ce
jour les pays qui reçoivent ce matériel
de les transformer en arme létale en
adjoignant par exemple une mitrailleuse
à un blindé de transport à ce propos la
sd se justifie la force conjointe du g5
sahel a été créé afin d'assurer la
sécurité de la sous région dans le but
de favoriser un développement
économique et social favorable aux
populations pourtant la situation semble
se dégrader dans cette zone en 2020
selon les chiffres de la clède près de
2400 civils ont été tués l'objectif de
pacification de la région voulue par la
france et celui du g5 ça elle semble à
la lumière de cette enquête loin d'être
atteint